>>> THERE IS MORBREAKING NEWS
WE'RE FOLLOWING TONIGHT.
A NEW YORK JUDGE RULING THAT DON
JR. AND DAUGHTER IVANKA, MUST,
REPEAT, MUST TESTIFY IN THE
CIVIL INVESTIGATION OF THEIR
BUSINESS PRACTICES.
KARA SCANNELL IS WORKING IT FOR
US.
AND JUST OUTSIDE OF TRUMP TOWER.
SO WHAT IS THE LATEST.
>> Reporter: SO FOLLOWING A
TWO-HOUR HEARING TODAY, THE
JUDGE ISSUED AN EIGHT-PAGE
OPINION AND SAID THAT THEY
SHOULDN'T HAVE COMPLY WITH THE
SUBPOENA BECAUSE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL IS WORKING IN PARALLEL
ON THE INVESTIGATION, THEY
SHOULD HAVE THE SAME RIGHT, THAT
MEANS THEY WANTED IMMUNITY IF
THEY WERE TO TESTIFY.
NOW THE JUDGE FULLY REJECTED THE
ARGUMENTS WRITING IN THE FINAL
ANALYSIS A STATE ATTORNEY
GENERAL COMMENCES INVESTIGATING
A BUSINESS ENTITY AND UNCOVERED
COPIOUS AMOUNTS OF FOOTBALL
FRAUD AND WANTS TO DEPOSE UNDER
ONLY, SHE HAS THE CLEAR RIGHT TO
DO SO.
AND CRITICIZED THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION RESPONSE THIS WEEK
WHEN THEIR LONG TIME ACCOUNTING
FIRM QUIT AND SAID THAT THEIR
NEARLY 10 YEARS OF FINANCIALS
SHOULD NO LONGER BE RELIED UPON.
TRUMP ORGANIZATION SAID THAT
BECAUSE MAZARS DID NOT DECLARE
THAT THERE WAS FRAUD, IT MEANT
THAT THE NEW YORK ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S INVESTIGATION WAS
MOOT.
THE JUDGE CALLED THAT
PREPOSTEROUS AND REMINISCENT OF
ALTERNATIVE FACTS.
NOW LAWYERS FOR THE FORMER
PRESIDENT AND HIS TWO SONS SAID
THEY WILL LIKELY APPEAL THE
RULING AND ASK FOR A STAY.
THAT IS TO PUT OFF THIS
THREE-WEEK DEADLINE WHEN THEY
WOULD HAVE TO TESTIFY.
ITs NOT CLEAR WHAT WILL HAPPEN
NEXT BUT THE LAWYERS DID SUGGEST
IF THEY ASSERT THEIR FIFTH
AMENDMENT AND NOT ANSWER ANY OF
THE QUESTIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>>> JOINING US NOW, CNN CHIEF
LEGAL ANALYST JEFFY TOOBIN AND
ABBY PHILLIP, THE ANCHOR OF
INSIDE POLITICS SUNDAY.
JEFFREY, FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND HIS KIDS ARGUED THAT SITTING
FOR A DEPOSITION WOULD VIOLATE,
THEY SAY, THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS, THIS JUDGE CERTAINLY
DISAGREED.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS RULING?
>> WELL IT WAS VERY
STRAIGHTFORWARD.
THIS IS A LEGITIMATE
INVESTIGATION AND THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL OF NEW YORK HAS SUBPOENA
POWER, SHE SUBPOENAED THE FORMER
PRESIDENT AND HIS TWO CHILDREN
AND THEY HAVE A CHOICE.
THEY COULD TESTIFY, OR THEY
COULD TAKE THE FIFTH.
THE PROBLEM WITH TAKING THE
FIFTH IS, FIRST OF ALL, IT IS
EMBARRASSING BUT THAT IS NO BAR
TO DOING IT, BUT IN A CIVIL
CASE, AS OPPOSED TO A CRIMINAL
CASE, A JURY COULD DRAW AN
ADVERSE APPEARANCE.
THE JURY COULD ASSUME, IF IT
COMES TO THAT, THAT YOU DID
SOMETHING WRONG.
THAT THERE IS ANNIN CREM NATING
ANSWER THERE.
SO THAT IS WHY THE TRUMP FAMILY
WANTS TO AVOID HAVING TO TAKE
THE FIFTH.
BUT THE ANSWER TO THAT IS TOO
BAD.
THAT IS WHAT THE LAW IS AND SO
IT IS NOT A SURPRISE THAT THE
JUDGE RULED THIS WAY.
>> ABBY, AFTER DODGING
ACCOUNTABILITY THROUGH SCANDAL
AFTER SCANDAL AFTER SCANDAL,
WHAT WILL IT SAY IF TRUMP IS
DEPOSED IN THIS VOINVESTIGATIONR
IF HE DECIDES TO PLEAD THE
FIFTH.
>> WELL FRANKLY, IF TRUMP
DECIDES TO TESTIFY, IT COULD END
DISASTROUSLY.
PARTLY BECAUSE HE COULD SIMPLY
TELL THE TRUTH, WHICH WOULD
LIKELY INCRIMINATE HIM.
THE REALITY IS THAT TRUMP IS NOT
THE PERSON TO BE RELIED UPON FOR
GIVING AN ACCURATE ASSESSMENT OF
HIS FINANCIAL -- HIS FINANCIAL
STANDING.
I MEAN, IT IS EVIDENCE BY THIS
LENGTHY STATEMENT THAT HE ISSUED
THIS WEEK IN WHICH HE MADE ALL
KINDS CLAIMS AND PUT ALL KINDS
OF NUMBERS AND STATEMENTS OUT
THERE THAT I'M SURE SENT HIS
LAWYERS RUNNING FOR SOME TYLENOL
FOR A HEADACHE.
THROUGH AS INCRIMINATING
SITUATION FOR TRUMP IF HE WERE
TO TESTIFY BECAUSE I'M NOT SURE
THAT HE REALLY UNDERSTANDS THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF WHAT HE COULD
SAY THAT COULD INCRIMINATE HIM.
AND AS JEFFREY SAID, IF HE
DOESN'T TESTIFY, THEN THE JURY
COULD MAKE A NEGATIVE INFERENCE
FROM THAT AND THAT COULD BE
DAMAGING FOR THE OUTCOME OF THE
CASE.
PERHAPS LESS SO FOR HIS STANDING
IN THE PUBLIC SPHERE.
WHAT THE PUBLIC LEARNS
EVENTUALLY ABOUT WHAT HE HAS TO
SAY ON THIS TOPIC.
>> JEFFREY, TRUMP'S LAWYERS HAD
ARGUED THAT HE DIDN'T HAVE
ENOUGH INFORMATION TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS, BUT AS ABBEY JUST
POINTED OUT, TRUMP THEN GOES OUT
THERE AND ISSUED THIS LENGTHY
STATEMENT FOR CLAIMING TO HAVE,
QUOTE, FANTASTIC ASSETS,
INCLUDING A BREAK DOWN IN DOLLAR
AMOUNTS.
HE'S NOT AN EASY CLIENT, IS HE?
>> HE'S NOT AN EASY CLIENTS.
HOWEVER, HE HAS TESTIFIED UNDER
OATH MANY TIMES AS WE KNOW.
HE'S VERY LITIGIOUS, BUT BEFORE
HE BECAME PRESIDENT, YOU KNOW,
HE IS ACTUALLY EXPERT AS A
FILIBUSTERING THROUGH THESE
EXAMINATIONS.
IT IS A VERY DIFFERENT STORY
NOW, NOW THAT HE'S A FORMER
PRESIDENT, NOW THAT THERE IS --
HE'S UNDER ALL OF THIS SCRUTINY.
BUT, YOU KNOW, I HAVE MADE THE
MISTAKE OF COUNTING HIM OUT
BEFORE, AND EVEN THOUGH THIS
INVESTIGATION IS VERY SERIOUS,
YOU KNOW, IT IS A LONG WAY FROM
AN INDICTMENT OR A CONVICTION OF
DONALD TRUMP FOR ANYTHING.
>> AND IT IS JUST ONE OF SEVERAL
LEGAL ISSUES, ABBEY, THAT TRUMP
IS FACING.
>> YEAH, ABSOLUTELY.
BUT THIS IS PROBABLY THE ONE
THAT HE'S THE MOST CONCERNED
ABOUT.
BECAUSE THIS HAS TO DO WITH HIS
PERSONAL AND HIS BUSINESS
FINANCES.
AND WE ALL KNOW THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT TRUMP HAS BEEN
VERY SENSITIVE ABOUT, HE FOUGHT
TO HIDE HIS TAX RETURNS FOR THIS
VERY REASON.
AND SOME PEOPLE AROUND HIM
BELIEVE THAT HE SEES THE
PRESIDENCY AS A WAY TO SHIELD
HIMSELF FROM SOME OF THESE TYPES
OF INVESTIGATIONS.
>> AND JUST ONE MORE POINT, THIS
IS NOT LIKE JANUARY 6 WHERE
THERE IS A TIME LIMIT IN HOW
LONG THE INVESTIGATION CAN